vous remarquerez j'ai mis mon sari fait
noir veste et noir pantalon et noir des
chaussures sont assortis l'année
dernière je vous invitais à secouer les
cocotiers pour ce qui était la secouer
les cocotiers canton et de sous c'est la
négation d'un lois de la gravité on est
sûr de ramasser les noix de coco sur la
figure cette année je me mets sous le
cocotier et je secoue le cocotier
en effet il ya des désobéissances majeur
et désobéissance mineurs les
désobéissance majeur on les a entendu
tout à l'heure c'était les formidables
exposés quant à lui dans cette première
partie de soirée depuis lé désobéissance
mineurs ce soir ch le bihan noir c'est
normal on excusera et je vais vous
parler d'un enterrement
et puis une deuxième raison qui fait que
j'ai une faim une désobéissance mineurs
c'est que j'ai des notes
c'est normal je vais vous parler de
l'âge et du vieillissement
en effet je vais vous inviter à
envisager de désobéir a osé désobéir pas
repensé par parole par action et par
omission
je vais vous parler du juste salaire la
notion de juste salaire elle est aussi
vieille que les impôts et si ça dure
seront aussi longtemps que les apps ont
donc en parler pendant un moment
saint thomas d'aquin c'est notre manière
léon xiii c'était au début du 20e siècle
et nombre de philosophes et
d'économistes du 19e et du 20e siècle on
parlait et se sont essayés au juste
salaire ils se sont essayés vraiment au
sens propre du terme puisque ils ont
écrit des essais sur le sujet
l'émergence du capitalisme avec des
moyens de production de plus en plus
onéreux a nécessité des capitaux de plus
en plus important ce qui a totalement
déséquilibrée les conditions de la
rémunération de ce qui est convenu
d'appeler dans certains milieux qui sont
plus en plus rare et qui représente 3%
la population les travailleurs en effet
un travailleur avant il avait un salaire
c'est quoi un salaire est en jeu
étymologiquement ça vient du mot
salariaux du sel en latin parce que
c'est et seront données aux soldats pour
lui permettre de survivre
c'était tout le sel est indispensable à
l'aviron payer en selle
calvin repris la même notion la
rémunération c'était tout juste ce qui
vous permettait de subsister il fallait
que vous soyez pas trop payer sinon vous
avez envie de travailler
si vous n'êtes pas assez payés vous
mourrez dont vous travaillez plus
échange de continuer à travailler
ben il faut vous donnez le juste salaire
cloud permet de survivre
vous imaginez bien que cette notion est
totalement dépassé c'est sur ce thème ce
soir que je vous propose de poser de
procéder à une instruction totalement
tendancieuses tendant à la peine de mort
d'un concept qui n'est qu'une imposture
je vais te dire devant vous le discours
le plus politiquement incorrect et
respectueux qui puisse exister c'est
celui qui attache à ses tout électeur et
notamment la ménagère de plus de 50 ans
c'est celle qui fait d'ailleurs le coeur
de l'électorat et en même temps des
émissions de télévision
en effet à partir de ce soir mon avenir
politique mon avenir politique est tout
tracé il s'arrête ici
je ne m'en relèverai pas j'en accepte
volontiers l'auguré autant mourir debout
et tout de suite et en bonne santé
en effet je vous propose de voter
l'abolition d'un privilège fondamental
de notre droit social et de nos
relations sociales vous propose qu'on
vive ensemble un genre de nuit du 4 août
1789 nuit au furent abolis les
privilèges et les droits féodaux
je vous propose de voler de voter
l'abolition da sigle que connaît tous
fonctionnaires tout syndicaliste
tout chef d'entreprise tout employeur
tout expert comptable tout avocat en
droit social
je vous propose de voter l'abolition
d'un système mal cuziat le plus
rétrograde qui ait jamais existé et qui
ait jamais germé dans un esprit humain
je vous propose de voter l'abolition du
gvt
alors c'est des mauvais esprits qui
pensent que j'ai voulu leur tgv ils se
trompent pas on l'aura et je me battrai
jusqu'à la mort pour y arriver
même si tous en temps je vois pas
beaucoup de courageux devant moi pour
allumer la foulée c'est pas grave le gvt
c'est le glissement vieillesse
technicité
c'est tout un programme vers la tombe
le glissement vieillesse technicité en
faisant cours le gvt c'est
l'augmentation automatique de la
rémunération à l'ancienneté
quel que soit le mérite ou le nom mérite
que l'on soit bon ou mauvais puissant ou
misérable le gvt c'est entre 1 1 et 2 %
de la masse salariale en france
j'étais hier après midi au conseil
d'administration de l'agencé régionale
de santé
c'est 1,7 pour cent je fais rien je suis
pas meilleur que les autres mais je suis
pas plus mauvais ma rémunération
augmenter automatiquement de 1 7% par an
si ce n'étaient que 1 %
ce serait 48,9 pour cent d'augmentation
nominal au bout de quarante ans de
carrière je vais essayer de vous
démontrer que le postulat du gvt est
infondée inconvenant notoirement
dangereux et scandaleusement encourager
il est infondée je sais que dans les
règles latine que j'ai apprise à l'école
avec beaucoup de peine en transpirant
énormément
on m'a appris la phrase ils devaient
tous tpt vire tout pour ceux qui ont
fait de la taça veut dire la qualité
vient tablier sans ça force le respect
voir l'affection mais c'est une parfaite
escroquerie exemple en matière
intellectuelle
depuis la réunification du titre de
champion du monde d'échecs qui est sans
doute l'exercice dans lequel on fait
plus appel à l'intellect humain quel est
l'âge des champions du monde d'échecs la
dynamique 31 ans magnus carlsen 23 ans
vous comprenez pourquoi j'ai vu notre
garry kasparov 22 ans bobby fischer 29
ans un avis karpov 24 ans maurice basque
et 32 ans apparemment après 30 ans aux
échecs
on est dans la vétusté des vues dans la
performance en matière sportive je ferai
à peine référence aux jeux olympiques le
doyen des champions olympiques français
c'est pierre jonquères d'oriola en 1960
8 sur un cheval mais je fall était
beaucoup plus jeune que lui il avait 44
ans le cavalier
tous les autres médaillés au moins de 44
ans alors vous me direz oui à jeannie
longo jusqu'à 63 ans
ok enfin bon on voit qui est son mari
les militaires prennent leur retraite si
vous le répéter je suis mort les
militaires prennent leur retraite
épuisés en moyenne à 44 ans les pompiers
sont fatigués à 50 ans et je vous parle
pas de la sncf pour laquelle la
pénibilité est inhérente au seul nom
d'entreprise
et pendant que certains pensent que
l'âge est un facteur de cessation
anticipée du travail accélérée par la
pénibilité
surtout pour ceux qui doivent remplir
les papiers les autres pensent que plus
on vieillit dans l'emploi plus on doit
être rémunéré c'est ça le gvt paradoxe
ne devrait pas et vous ne vous posez pas
la question de savoir du seigneur de
plus de 50 ans qui quand il a un emploi
dans l'entreprise vous chaque année de
plus en plus cher et quand il a plus
d'emploi vont plus rien du tout comment
on fait pour gérer ça vous trouvez pas
c'est un paradoxe
enfin ne vous posez pas la question de
la pénibilité qui consiste à proposer à
un retrait une retraite améliorée à
celui qui pourra pas en profiter
plutôt que de mieux rémunérés dans sa
période de production
celui qui produit des efforts
particuliers ce qui améliorera son
niveau de vie et sa retraite en même
temps en france dans ce pays on s'est
organisé pour gagner sa croûte
quand on n'a plus de dents pour la
manche et si le système non on va
déborder le temps si vous continuez
et si système est premièrement infondées
il est aussi deuxièmement inconvenant
pourquoi payer - un jeune riche d'un
diplôme tout neuf dont il a les
connaissances les plus récentes
alors qu'un ancien souvent fonctionne
sur sa routine c'est le gel était
paradoxe vous ne trouvez pas alors deux
objections direz-vous la première c'est
qu'avec l'ancienneté
on acquiert de l'expérience c'est sans
doute vrai elle vient entre contrepartie
la perte des neurones de connaissances
vieillissante d'une mémoire d'un air
fort menthe et d'une plasticité
intellectuelle réduite puisqu'elle plus
quelques autres exemples où quelques
autres inconvénients que vu mon âge je
me garderai bien vous décrire en outre
et enfin je doute que l'expérience
contrebalance tous les inconvénients qui
précède deuxième objection si on paie
moins bien les anciens ils ne pourront
plus aider les jeunes j'avais écrit et
spock et que voilà j'aime mieux vous
dire foutaise
si l'on paie mieux les jeunes les vieux
n'auront plus besoin de les aider et ce
sera infiniment mieux ici et pourquoi
payer mieux les vieux quand ils en plus
dedans pour manger leur route alors
qu'elle est jeune avec une rémunération
réduits doivent tout à la fois fonder
leur famille accueillir leurs enfants
acquérir leur logement et s'adonner aux
activités permises en leur âge alors que
pour les plus anciens ils ont
normalement moins de besoin je peux vous
la tester troisième point en plus d'être
infondées inconvenant le gvt est
dangereux en effet quand un ancien part
à la retraite
il est souvent remplacé par un jeune
dont la rémunération est la moitié de
celle de celui qui part et vous croyez
que les jeunes vont voir longtemps les
anciens partir à la retraite et cotisé e
pour la retraite sur un salaire de
moitié inférieur à celui de ceux qui
sont partis pour garantir à celui qui
est parti un pouvoir d'achat supérieur à
celui qu'ils ont en eux en les
remplaçant dans le même emploi ça va pas
durer très longtemps et ceux de mon âge
il ferait bien de commencer à numéroter
leur appétit
enfin je voudrais vous dire que le
système est dangereuse m'encourager et
ce notamment de deux façons par la
réduction des charges sur les bas
salaires
je sais que je peux me faire bien voir
de tout le monde mais c'est pas grave
j'en ai l'habitude réel scandale
moi je te paye moins il ya de charge est
comme ça t'en salaires plus il est bas
moi je te paye plus gagnent dessus et
plus vite tu crèves totalement
inconvenant
qu'est-ce qui est allé à inventer la
réduction des seins des charges sur les
bas salaires
c'est constant avec tous les
gouvernements depuis 1974
y en a pas un qui a dérogé à la règle et
au delà de ce qu'on a pu inventer pour
faire en sorte que l'on puisse couper
l'ascenseur social
on a en privilégiant les bas salaires
couper définitivement les câbles de
l'ascenseur social c'est désespérant et
criminels et nous sommes tous coupables
et le deuxième système qui est
particulièrement pernicieuse c'est celui
du crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
le cic aujourd'hui vous savez je vais
très technique de seconde que le cic
s'applique pour les salaires inférieurs
à 2,7 fois le smic si je te paye deux
points cette fois le smic
je bénéficie du cic de 2850 euros de
crédit d'impôt si je te paye 2 cette
fois le smic + 1 euro je perles 2850
euros de crédits d'impôt et vous croyez
que c'est avec ça qu'on va donner envie
à des jeunes d'avoir des carrières
scientifiques des carrières d'ingénieur
des carrières de promotion sociale
après avoir mis pour les femmes un plan
de route vers l'or mais tant pour les
jeunes un plafond de rémunération belles
perspectives d'avenir
n'est ce pas alors je vous en conjure
gardons nous de donner du corps à la
terrible phrase de la bruyère dans les
caractères il écrit la plupart des
hommes emploi la première partie de leur
vie à rendre l'autre misérable c'est ce
qui va se passer si on continue à
privilégier les bas salaires pour les
jeunes en activité
c'est ce que nous risquons chers amis
sinon orange us ne réagissons réagissant
pas contre cette injustice flagrante le
sais que mon propos est infiniment
critiquable
le plus critiquable ce serait ne pas en
parler on parle donc rations caton
l'ancien vous souvenez celui qui à
chacun de ses discours à rome
quel que soit le sujet disait des lada
est carthago je vous invite à ce rang
semble s que nous crions delenda est le
gvt
merci beaucoup